it is the honor and the privilege
of my life he became leader in lockdown
and since then kiestama's been busy not
just pulling pints and clapping for
carers
but wrestling control of his party i
made my decision
in relation to rebecca long bailey
yesterday and put out my
statement and i stand by that piling
pressure on boris johnson
the prime minister typically flippant
simply said it's
not true and seeing his poll ratings
rise
i think the public view generally cures
armor as somebody that's a bit dull but
very competent and i can
actually think of worse things for an
opposition leader to be i mean
starmer is has proven himself to be very
sort of forensic
and at prime minister's question time
and certainly has been doing what many
feel an opposition should be doing at
the time of national crisis
a crisis calls for competence and in the
era of covert 19
kiyosama's big achievement has been
pinning the pm down
on detail with largely positive results
the uk was slow into lockdown slow on
testing
slow on tracing his sacking of left wing
leadership rival rebecca long bailey
in an anti-semitism row underlined his
ruthlessness
and he's carefully negotiated sensitive
issues
like black lives matter on the one hand
he's doing better
than his immediate predecessors and he's
doing better than boris johnson on a
number of measures
on the other hand he does have a very
big task because
the scale of the mountain that labour
has to climb
if it's to get anywhere near government
in the future
is really quite considerable named after
kia hardy labour's first leader
kiyosama's enemies paint him as a
remainer lawyer
before politics he ran the crown
prosecution service
and as jeremy corbyn's shadow brexit
secretary
he designed the policy which played a
part in labour's election defeat
jeremy corbyn's actions on anti-semitism
have made us
the nasty party we are the racist party
in the seven months since ruth smith
lost her job representing stoke-on-trent
north
this place desperately needs a labour
government that anger has been replaced
with optimism for me what's most
important
is that we have a leader that wants to
be the prime minister
that cares more about who runs the
country than who runs the labour party
and that is an incredibly important
thing
this town was built on labor but now all
three of its mps
are conservatives stoke is just the sort
of place
kiestama needs to win back if he's to
become prime minister
but first he'll need some policies
andrew fisher wrote labour's last two
election manifestos
he believes kirstama should be radical i
think in normal circumstances if you're
an opposition you think it's four years
away from an election you wouldn't set
out
policy in any detail at this stage
that's right but it's clear unemployment
is going to rise
possibly to levels not seen since the
80s so you can set out quite detailed
quite
radical policy at this time and i think
now the labour party is critiquing what
the government is doing rightly
i think it needs to set out what should
be done instead
one thing is clear from kierstama's
first 100 days
he's completely focused on becoming
prime minister
his only option now is to play the long
game
joe pike sky news westminster